okay don't make fun i can't ask him if i
can use his labs a computer right now
because he's doing his
morning breathing exercises so can i
just move my i have a hard wire i can
find this
the mesh here and then plug it in can we
just subscribe
that would be good yes okay conan stop
it
conan stop it can i do a quick do you
mind if i do a quick recap of what's
happening for those just joining us
we haven't we haven't even begun to
record today the reason we haven't even
begun is that sona got on and
uh had a lot of technical problems we
found out that she's moved to a
different part of her
predominantly oatmeal colored home then
she
uh she kept freezing and we couldn't do
the work that we
need to do and uh then we found out
what's the problem so and she said well
i'm
i'm not using tax computer that's her
husband tack and uh
i said well why can't we just go over
and use tax computer that's the one you
always use and it's never a problem
and she left and then she came back very
quietly
and said i can't disturb tac he's doing
his breathing
exercises we're finding out a lot about
someone's home life a home made of
oatmeal
b husband cannot be disturbed when he's
doing his breathing exercises
i too do breathing exercises it's called
living
i just breathe in and breathe out and go
about my business
uh i've been doing it since uh a little
baby
my parents before me there's before them
i think this probably goes back to
a period of time when we crawled
out of the sea and started
taking in the oxygen through
our newly formed lungs
of course tac needs to reserve a time to
do this matt's not listening either
matt's busy
making uh his house look more like
a newsroom from the 1960s
the nicest thing anyone's ever said to
them some cameras in the background
uh is about to tell us that in 10
minutes
nixon and kennedy will debate i don't
know where sona is she's creeping around
this is a problem oh what happened
this is a problem can you guys hear me
yeah okay this is this is problematic
gonna be fine
sauna relax relax maybe you should
breathe just breathe in
through the nose breathe in through the
nose fill your belly with air
and then out through the mouth then
breathe into the nose
do you guys even need me for today can i
maybe i should just
and then breathe out through the mouth
sit this one out
breathe in through the nose just sit
this one out
and breathe out through the mouth and
then i want you to
gently and quietly move to an area
that has wi-fi into the nose
i'm hardwired now oh good why would you
want to sit this out it's so much fun
for you
this is no this is awful